oh my god forever
it was never really referenced on the
city that Roxy was Stephanie Pratt's
friend they were best friends
um Roxy and Stephanie we all went to
high school together
actually you knew Whitney better than I
do and I went to middle school high
school we really actually dated my best
friend in high school for like her like
3-year boyfriend was my best friend so
the world is too weird that like you
know I was hanging out a Whitney all the
time and then all of a sudden I'm like
what you know life is a trip my
boyfriend when I first started filming
the hills was good friends with Spencer
they actually wrote a script together it
was all this very like intertwined West
Side private school thing we had going
on Stephanie and Roxy were best friends
in high school and yeah and that's how
the whole thing happens it's interesting
because we never got to know that you
and Spencer knew of each other before
right that we actually like when I was a
history yeah yeah um I know I don't know
why we I think sometimes I thought about
why they never really created it that
storyline or like tried to amp that up a
little bit
missed opportunity